now i'm going to talk to you guys about
when it might be ideal
get involved with a single mommy
finish off on a better note here's the
thing
if none of these conditions exist okay
so i'm gonna go through them again
cuckholder you can't do anything about
so that's always gonna exist you know
you're basically signing up for your own
cuckoldry when you start to raise
uh another guy's kids let's say you have
responsibility and authority
okay so let's take off that box if you
have responsibility with authority with
her because she supports you
she enters your frame she supports your
mission she's a compliment to your life
not the focus of it
and she allows you it's funny that i
have to allows you know
and you have responsibility and
authority
in connection with those two things
which let's be honest this is unlikely
but let's say that it is
there let's take off the box so there's
number one you have responsibility with
authority
in that relationship she does not have a
victim mindset she does not
subscribe to any kind of uh like
third wave feminist ideology where the
patriarchy needs to be smashed and all
men are bad
and i'm not going to make you sandwiches
or anything like that
if she if she does not have a victim
mindset and if you
are able to have responsibility in
conjunction with authority
let's keep going there's two right there
okay what are the chances those two
happen we're already priests them let's
go to financial issues now
let's say she doesn't have any financial
issues there's no student loan debt she
doesn't have a liberal arts degree with
a hundred thousand dollars in debt
and nothing going on she's she's got it
together
okay maybe she set up her own company
she's highly successful makes a quarter
million dollars a year like you do as
well as kevin from sales
right um you have a scenario like that
let's take off that box so there's
three now okay and the last one
your reprioritization let's say she does
not because this kind of goes
hand in hand with
um the ones earlier but let's say that
you do not need to re-prioritize your
life
you still have your boys weekend you can
still go boating
she's not going to curtail any of your
hobbies
and again she's a compliment to your
life she's not the focus and all that
sort of stuff
um thanks marco appreciate that um
then and only then if you have children
that are the same age and the same
gender then it might be
and she's hot still okay obviously you
know you got to be attracted to her
then and only then it might be ideal to
date a single mom
now i ask you what are the chances of
her not having a victim mindset you have
responsibility and authority hand in
hand
um financial issues are not you know a
problem she's not bringing
debt to the table with other man with
other men's children in some cases
and you don't need to re-prioritize your
life where you come in like seventh
place
behind the pecking order of her kids her
kids knees her work issues the fight
that she had with becky uh the other day
in hr
her big wine drinking nights her salsa
nights with her girlfriends and her cats
if all of those things are out of the
way and you do not have to re-prioritize
and your kids are about the same age and
the same gender because again if she's
got a son and you bring a daughter to
the table you got risk involved you got
the big risk involved you're gonna
expose your daughter to potential risk
then it might be ideal to date a single
mom okay
you